hey this is presto Walker reminding you
to mind your decisions this comes from
an Oxford interview question you are
given a coin not necessarily fair that
sometimes shows heads and sometimes
shows tails if you toss a tails you get
one pound and the game continues so you
get to toss again if you toss a heads
however you get nothing and the game
ends the question is what is the average
amount you will win in the game in other
words what is the expected value of the
game I adapted this from a video I saw
on the YouTube channel Kurumi pause the
video if you'd like to give it a try and
when you're ready keep watching to learn
how to solve this problem
[Music]
now before we go calculating I'm going
to prove this series is absolutely
convergent this is so we can deal with
the infinite series and not get any
crazy results we'll write T to be the
probability of getting a tails H to be 1
minus T which is the probability of
getting a heads we'll write W to be a
random variable equal to the winnings of
the game we want to calculate e of W if
we toss a heads we'll get 0 if we toss a
tails and then a heads we'll get 1 if we
toss two tails and then a heads we'll
get 2 and this pattern continues so how
do we calculate this infinite series
well first substitute in the
probabilities of heads and tails we get
the following infinite sum now we're
going to prove that this is absolutely
convergent the general term of this
series is T to the power of K multiplied
by the quantity 1 minus T multiplied by
K starting at K is equal to 0 now we'll
use Dalembert ratio test of consecutive
terms
well then simplify this and we see what
happens when K goes to infinity this
limit will go to T and that's going to
be less than 1 because T is the
probability of getting a tails which is
strictly between 0 & 1
thus this series is absolutely
convergent so now let's evaluate this
series how are we going to do that the
first thing we'll do is we'll distribute
the term 1 minus T now since we prove
this series is absolutely convergent we
can regroup the terms with no issues we
won't get a ridiculous result like the
sum of all natural numbers is equal to
negative 1/12
so we'll first group these T squared
terms then we will go ahead and do the
same thing and group the T cubed terms
then we'll continue to do that these T
squared terms will simplify to be T
squared the T cubed terms will simplify
to be T cubed and this pattern will
continue so we end up with a simple
geometric series and this is equal to T
all over 1 minus it's common ratio of T
and that's our answer
so I think this
is a pretty cool way to solve the
problem but there's another way that I
think is also interesting it uses the
law of total expectation for a finite
random variable X where we have a sample
space going from a 1 to a n it takes the
following formula we take the
conditioned expectation multiply it by
the probability and then add up all of
these terms now this formula looks very
complicated but it'll actually be useful
because these conditional expectations
are sometimes easier to calculate so
we'll condition on the first coin toss
when we start the game we expect to win
e of W then on the first toss we might
get a heads in that case we're going to
get 0 and the game is going to end but
we might also get a tails in which case
we'll get 1 pound the game is going to
restart and then we'll still continue to
expect a of W so to put it another way
you might throw a heads and get 0 or you
might throw a tails in which case you
win one pound and the game restarts so
you now expect to win a of W plus one so
I'll write this in a simple algebra
equation we first use the formula for
the law of total expectation and then we
substitute what we just calculated we
then simplify this equation and now we
have a linear equation in a of W we then
collect the terms of e of W and then
divide both sides and we get our answer
the average winnings will be T all over
one minus T so we solved this using a
simple linear equation so I think this
method is also very interesting to learn
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on YouTube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
you